un peu de zumba pour prendre soin de sa
santé ça peut tout changer au forum
santé et bien-être de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un des messages que l'on
veut faire passer avec ces initiations
sportives
je vois au fur et à mesure de mon
activité mon métier que le plus les gens
font du sport mais ils sont dans leur
vie quotidienne comme on est bien dans
son corps bien dans sa tête c'est
toujours les mots qu'on l'emploie
si vous n'avez pas mal au dos vous êtes
plus plus tranquille le plus libre pour
pour faire vos mouvements et la vie tous
les jours des ateliers tai-chi du body
pump et du pilates était proposée ce
week-end comme chaque année un fort mais
reste le premier objectif du forum la
nouveauté de cette édition une façon
plus positive de parler de la santé on a
élargi la notion de santé à la notion de
santé et bien-être puisqu'on est résolu
et santé oms depuis 2006 et à ce titre
en fait on a l'idée de que la santé
c'est pas seulement liée au physique
mais aussi à l'émotionnel au psy chic à
différentes composantes et en ce sens on
a convié des structures qui travaillent
autour des notions de bien être les
acteurs habituels de la santé étaient
également présents près d'un millier de
personnes sont venues chercher des
renseignements sur les différents
établissements de santé du territoire ou
même parfois se faire dépister
comme ici sur le stand de l'association
des diabétiques des yvelines aujourd'hui
le diabète touche plus de 3 5 millions
de personnes à travers le monde en
france 700 mille individus s'ignorent ce
qui est un chiffre relativement
conséquents ce qui veut dire que sur les
deux jours où nous sommes présents sur
le forum de santé à saint quentin en
yvelines
nous sommes amenés à dépister des gens
qui s'ignore nombreux sont ceux qui se
rendent à li ps après ce premier contact
l'institut de promotion de la santé
accueille chaque année 8000 personnes
des forums itinérants sont prévues
prochainement à magny les hameaux et à
elancourt